[Music]
how are you guys all doing out there
all right so i'm sean sticks larkin this
is my co-host howard doss right here
from the cocktails and cocktails podcast
um if you guys are not listening to it
shame on you but uh sign up
so this is the first time we've actually
done a live podcast obviously in front
of an audience so it's up to you guys to
make this enjoyable for us as much as
we're trying to make it enjoyable for
you
so um
for those of you that aren't familiar
with our podcast
i'm a retired police officer from tulsa
oklahoma
[Applause]
just retired last year after 25 years
howard here good personal friend of mine
is a traveling nurse
yeah
i'm a true helper of people yeah he's
he's a hero unlike us policemen now yes
but true here
uh no truthfully so howard and i and
jason who's back here running the camera
we're all friends uh back in tulsa and
we are all
bourbon collectors connoisseurs whatever
you want to call it
yeah and so
during the heat of covid live pd was off
the air um
little bit louder
thank you
fingers crossed it'll be back but
[Music]
um
howard was working up in new york city
during the heat of covid back when it
was the the nastiest that it was
and he had been up there for six months
yeah wow
he's been up there for a while and he
missed us
and i flew up to new york literally
basically picked me up at the airport
and we made a road trip back we stopped
in kentucky too and picked up bourbon we
we we picked up a lot of bra
we picked up like 80 bottles of bourbon
we we look like bootleggers we wear
bootlickers
so but anyways on our way back he and i
just talk and you know we've been
friends for several years and everybody
likes police stories everybody likes cop
stories a police officer goes to a party
you know everybody wants you know tell
me something crazy that's happened that
type of deal and so just the three days
of us driving the time we spent in
kentucky uh we just came up man we
should try to start a podcast we're
we're good at bs and
you know whatever you want to call it so
shit talking yeah um if you listen to
our podcast there is profanity we talk
about we're all grown-ups here
but you know we came up with the idea of
cocktails and cocktails and so that's
how it came to be we started last may
it's still slowly growing we basically
have anybody that's kind of touching the
law enforcement world from
police officers that have been shot in
the line of duty to
victims of crimes to
prosecutors we've had you know
ex-convicts we just did cyber crime yeah
i mean you name it we've had them on
there so
uh that's kind of how we came to be so
again we're happy to be here at crimecon
this is our first time doing anything
like this live so all right sean enough
of that so that's who we are does
everybody know who that guy is on the
other end
so you will hear from him mostly not us
yes
but as the name of our podcast is
cocktails and cocktails we have a drink
with every episode that we do
it uh varies from
sometimes just something either howard
or i choose that we like to the truly
awful like apple
that's the worst
we don't drink that
we we drink white
white wine every once in a while but no
most the time it's whiskey we like corn
wine yeah
so so so gil here is not a big whiskey
drinker but he has uh he we have some
red wine in a plastic slurpee cup
because we're bougie
but we do have a cocktails and cocktails
bottle from a company called nashville
barrel company out of nashville
tennessee
let us uh we we had we basically picked
a whole barrel and had it bottled up and
we've been selling it and the
the profit from it all profits go to the
national fallen officers fund so that's
what the fund goes to
so with that being said cheers to all of
you guys cheers cocktails
[Applause]
all right guys so we have gil carrillo
here with us
uh at crimecon 2022.
uh gil
for everybody here for us included
how did you get into law enforcement
how'd this whole thing start for you
first off before i tell you how i got in
there
this is pure insanity
i cannot believe
i'm humbled i don't know whether to
laugh to cry to run
uh you drink
a few people are just number one you're
far too kind
to this old weathered man
so it's my cheers
to you yeah
we don't need an excuse to drink okay
now here we go
i was 17 years old a cop took my ass
home and told my parents signed for him
to get off the streets or he's gonna end
up dead or in prison so at 17 they
signed for me to get off the streets i
ended up in the united states army
ended up i turned 18 november 29th of
that year
two months later i was in a little town
called
country called vietnam
one year of combat i came back
and
now i was a different person and then i
i really had three goals in life
uh one goal was
i wanted to go to college i had six
sisters nobody in my family cousins
nobody had ever gone to college in my
family
i wanted to go to college
number two
i wanted to become a cop
because i wanted to give back what that
cop gave to me he saved my life
number three
this is the one now pay attention i'm
gonna get a bunch of laws
i got a dear john when i was in vietnam
i wanted to come back number three was i
wanted to hook up with that
ex-girlfriend of mine
get her eating out of the palm of my
hand
and revenge was gonna be mine
i got out in june of 70 started college
immediately the summer session
got to become a cop you know that
by september of 70 i had her eaten out
of the palm of my hand
the day after christmas 1970.
yeah we got married
we just celebrated our 51st wedding
anniversary yeah
and if you stop to think about it if i'd
have killed her that first year i'd
already been walking the streets of free
man
that got me into law enforcement
jail time patrol time detective time
38 years as a cop 26 working murders uh
and here i am
in
paris hotel
downtown las vegas
with all of these people god bless
america
it's a beautiful spot
that's how i became a cop
so back in 71
71 just a show of hands how many people
were even born then yeah who was in line
okay yeah yeah so okay
so that was a long uh you know that was
a while ago
um
law enforcement's changed a lot
during your your tenure i imagine yeah
um when you first got on the department
was going into homicide something that
was a goal of yours or was it just dumb
luck or just no no i was working patrol
i got out of patrol and because of my
the expertise that i built up prior to
coming on the department
i got to go
i was working i started the first plane
closed gang unit
in a patrol stage htla which back in the
70s was the
headquarters for gangs
in the united states
it was big
and it was nothing
murders all over the place shootings
going on
and at that time then back in the late
70s they decided you know what we need
to have a specialty unit
to work gang related homicides
and i had seen as a patrol cop
homicide guys get out there
and they were creme de la creme
i'd be working at three o'clock in the
afternoon they'd get out there on a
murder i'd come back to work the next
day
the same guys are there same clothes
still digging hard they were the best of
the best
and i set my goals early i said
that's what i want to be when i grow up
it takes on my department still today an
average of minimally 15 years to get the
sheriff's homicide bureau
i did it nine and a half
and they asked me to get up there
for my gang expertise and the rest is
history i love working murders there
it's uh it's not a job it's a lifestyle
yeah and it's a tough lifestyle yeah
it's tough on the family i know you've
talked about that before about how
difficult obviously just the job in law
enforcement is let alone homicide let
alone homicide and 51 years
still made it 51 years
so what was your murder count in 51
years i've read accounts that say that
you worked on 700 cases right not not 51
years that's the marriage oh six one's
the marriage i thought that was the
marriage all right go ahead
almost 52 if you're not married
uh
the murder account
when you when you talk how many cases
were actually my assigned cases or if
it's a heavy murder case they send four
guys out to work on it or if it's an
officer involved shooting
so they have me counted down for right
around 800
uh cases being involved in or and and
some of those
my last five years a homicide bureau
i was a homicide lieutenant so i had 14
homicide cops working for me i'd go out
my name goes out on every report so
every murder they went on i went on
and i'd be the supervisor out there
which means
just stay out of their way let the pros
work
and all i do is sign their overtime
slips and do their evaluations but you
go out there
and they come to me for advice once in a
while
and
my name gets assigned to the case so
all those cases are involved what was
the first murder that you uh
investigated i can remember the first
murders if it were yesterday because it
was at a
park rosewood park and firestone
the florence community of
south la
it was on a sunday afternoon
and i remember because the guy that i
was going out to the murder with he says
hey if we get called out
he says you're probably going to be
be there before i am because i rent a
carpenter shop out of my garage
so if it happens during the day i got to
clean up clean up the garage before i
get out of the so you'll be out there i
said how can you do this
this is my first murder case he says you
get out there
you'll be in a suit and tie and they
think you're gonna know everything there
absolutely is to know about murder cases
your sheriff's homicide
he says you know where we start taking
measurements you know what we start to
do
and i said yeah but what happens if
murder's in east l.a where i just left
patrol from
he says well tough shit kid welcome to
homicide
so it was at murder
and i remember it well because we did
everything we had to do preliminarily
and it's about 10 o'clock at night and i
said he looks at me says
well what do we have to do now kid
i said well we got to take the stuff
over to the crime lab and he said nope
and i said okay well we need to go see
if we can contact these people over here
he said
nope
and i said well then
what time is it i think it's time to
have a drink
i agree
did i mention policing has changed so
here we are having a drink yeah yeah
[Applause]
so he said
the guy tells me he says okay
here it is
you got to learn his rule right away
he says
two drink limit when we go out okay
three drinks you're in for the night
i said okay
so i went there and i said
okay here we are i'm with the big boys
now let me buy you your first drink
[Music]
he says no
i buy the first drink you're my trainee
i said okay yes sir thank you
neck drink says
now you can buy me a drink so i bought
him a drink
and he says okay now
this is the last one this is the one we
call
one for the ditch
this we ditched this place and go home
i said okay
he says i'm buying the first one for the
ditch
poured our drink got that he says you
made a mistake kid i said why since i
said two drink limit we go to number
three we're in for the night have
another one
and we stood there till they closed
oh yeah
did you guys ever solve the murder yes
we did okay yes we did
from the bar well i want to go back to
just you talking about also uh obviously
we're going to get into the night
stalker stuff which i'm sure everybody
here is very you know
intrigued by
but
you mentioned being a lieutenant in the
homicide bureau yes and from my
understanding you were the first
hispanic officer for the l.a county
sheriff's department to hold that the
rank above a sergeant within that bureau
is that correct that's correct yeah what
year did that happen
uh that happened in uh
thank you i'm i'm yeah
that happened 2004
so still pretty late
2004. yeah it was late yeah they're
they're june the second of this year
they're having their 100 year
anniversary of sheriff's homicide bureau
so it wasn't until 2004 they had their
first
the first man above the rank of sergeant
that was hispanic and your guy's a
sheriff is hispanic now correct yes he
is yeah alex
yeah you're a fan
i'm a fan of his he's in he's in a shit
pot full of trouble right now he is he
is
but
you know according to the news
he is because you got one lady saying
one thing and him saying something else
it'll eventually come out in court makes
good for political cannon fodder right
now he has done more for the county in
all the years i've been with them than
any sheriff prior to him i'm not saying
he's been the best i'm saying he's done
more he's a good guy he's got my vote
he's got my money anybody from l.a
county
vote villanueva
no yeah i mean listen the sheriff is a
political position i mean it's an
elected position uh i
obviously the city of los angeles los
angeles there's a lot of anti-police
stuff even throughout the politics there
and he is battling the d.a there very
publicly uh you know
the lack of prosecution on cases people
being released and so forth and he's
calling him out for it and it it upsets
people
he is calling him out for it he's been
the first guy since peter pitches that
has called any of those politicos out
he's done it he's called him out he's
showing
in our county 23 of the independent
cities
have
publicly said vote or no confidence for
this guy
uh
recently a off-duty lapd officer got
killed in sheriff's area yeah when it
was car rather than guarding the local
d.a
we went to the feds for
filing prosecution because
rda will not file enhancements
he does not believe in the death penalty
does not believe in life without
eligibility parole let's all coddle him
get him
pat him on a poo-poo and send it back
out on the streets
so
no he's i hope he wins
uh
he just fights everything here no he
does and gill and and just obviously i'm
from tulsa oklahoma howard is jason is
as well we had a police officer uh two
years ago we had two cops shot one of
them was a rookie four weeks out of the
academy
shot in the head
his sergeant who was with him was shot
in the head and killed
his name was craig johnson i was his
first supervisor when he got released
out of the academy he worked for me
the trial had been going on the last
three weeks
um he was convicted and just
yesterday was it yesterday yeah we flew
in yesterday yeah it was yesterday um
they came back with a guilty for
first-degree murder and gave him the
death penalty so god bless him yeah
so that's what happens when you kill a
cop in tulsa oklahoma that's a little
bit different as it should be
i mean uh
i don't
let
let god sort it out there you go
all right
you guys want to hear about night
stalker stuff don't you yeah
[Applause]
what do you want to hear i don't
all right so this was uh
march 17 1985 st patrick's day the luck
of the irish wasn't with maria hernandez
that night
oh dale okazaki
keep going yeah you're doing good
that that started it was the first case
just up for murder just like any other
murder routine mundane murder
go out there this one was different dale
okazaki was roommates with maria
hernandez maria hernandez got home
she goes
into her
garage
she lived in a uh a
condo so the door leads right in inside
she heard a
deliberate noise he made a deliberate
noise
uh and i was speaking with someone
earlier
there's a sexual deviation that says
when someone points a gun at you a gun
at you they're not always
going to kill you they want to see that
frightened look
well he did it intentionally
and she said no no put her hands up in
front of her
didn't do it like he said he pulled the
trigger
she went down
he thought he had killed her she the
bullet hit the gun hit the keys that
were being held in her hand
penetrated her hand but didn't exit she
went down the ground the door was
already unlocked he went inside
she got up hit the door ran out the
garage and if she's running down
and she's running away
if you were in a theater eating your
popcorn you go run maria run
and then she hears that second gunshot
inside and she runs towards the front of
the apartment and you're saying no don't
be stupid maria run the other way
she ran to the front
that second gunshot was when he killed
her roommate
and same thing first we found contusions
at the back of her head he hit her in
the back of the head with a gun first
she went down in the kitchen
there was a kitchen counter there she
then put her hands on the kitchen
counter lifted her head up see where
he's at he was on the other side of the
counter with a gun as soon as her head
came up he popped her right in the head
he then leaves out the front door sees
maria out there
there's a car they start playing cat and
mouse going back and forth one way or
the other
and finally she just throws her hands up
in the air and says hey you already shot
me once don't shoot me again
so
he then
very casually puts the gun down by his
side walks away and that was the very
first murder
and that
told me that night there's something
different
why didn't he kill her why did he let
her go
when he could have she wasn't afraid the
next time
you know why did he shoot her in head
why didn't they shoot her in the back of
the head when he had her inside an hour
later
silenu was inside of her vehicle
she stopped
and this is probably about two miles
away from the first murder occurred
cops get their monterey park different
uh
jurisdiction
they get there because neighbors have
called in a fight between boyfriend and
girlfriend and what has happened is
she puts
she's driving he blocks her she puts the
car in reverse backs into another car so
she's stuck
he then goes up pulls her out of the
side of the car
shoots her twice
on the abdomen
and then leaves her in the street and
goes
why
didn't he just shoot her when she was in
the car
why
did he leave her what was going on
and so that told me
there's something different and and that
led to the beginning of
somebody doing there was an attempt
kidnapping with kids
the kids uh
did drawings the drawing we did
with maria hernandez
because she survived
and she said this is what the suspect
looked like the kids did an identicate
nobody in here will remember identique
that's where they
used to use the old acetate layovers oh
yeah
yeah yeah so
the guy said hey i just did a child
abduction here's what she said
and they look like they were done by the
same person
and you look at the physical
descriptions
they were the same maria hernandez
was a little closer to me because
when i'm inside the apartment
conducting the crime scene of maria
hernandez
the deputy opens the front door and i'm
silhouetted on the inside
so he says hey gil
the mother of your victim at the
hospital wants to talk to you and i said
okay just ask her please give me two
more minutes i'll be out there to talk
to her
and then all of a sudden i hear hey
gilbert is that you
and nobody calls me gilbert
i'm cool i'm guilt
and i said yes it is
and she says it's me pauline and i look
i said pumpkin is that you she says yes
pumpkin
lived three doors down from me when i
grew up
my mother and father baptized
pumpkins baby who was maria hernandez
really and so it really brought things a
little closer
uh
pumpkin got divorced
and ended up marrying somebody else and
they moved away i hadn't seen and seen
maria since she was in diapers
and
that was just the first night of the
case and then things just developed
evidence came in
so much evidence uh
it was tough trying to sell old cops
uh
how many people saw the documentary
[Applause]
a few
in the documentary it stressed that
i was pushing the theory and i was
saying there's one man doing it and they
all thought i would essentially i was
full of shit
and i was a young punk trying to make a
name for myself
but i could see things that they they
didn't
and
i was articulating what they were
that were
a sex crimes investigator
would had knowledge of
and i got my sex crimes investigator in
the documentary i identify robert
morneau
who was a retired fbi agent who gave me
the knowledge
to work the case made me a better
instructor
everything he did was through humor to
get his vehicle his point across
uh that's what started everything and
when you start looking at something like
simple as a shoe print a shoe print of a
bsu which we found
i can tell you without equivocation on
january 9 1985 1 356 pair model 440 if
he has arrived in new york from taiwan
for distribution throughout the us of
which six pair ended up in the state of
california one pair ended up in the city
of los angeles wow
so
we did a lot a lot of work everything
came together it came together because
of the work of a lot of assisting guys
that were working the case
citizens called up
women sometimes you can be so cruel
we had women calling in more of their
ex-husbands
that's enough suspects
it was unbelievable but it
but it all came out to be good
the arrest was actually made august 31st
of 1985
uh
it just it was a whirlwind
my family moved back home
my wife and kids moved out august the
8th
they came back
september 2nd
[Applause]
i was a hero then
i mean i was a piece of shit while i was
working the case i was a hero
and it was all right oh yeah now you
want me now i'm in the news now it's
good so so your family moved out because
of just how immersed you were in the
case that was the time the dedication
they they moved down
primarily because
of fear once that documentary landed
after the documentary hit
i apologized to my wife
because at that time i knew my job was
catch killer her job was the house and
the kids
i never
thought about the fear factor she was
scared to death
you know and she was scared for the kids
i was never fearful because i had a gun
i had partners right she was there alone
so she moved most of the time it was
either it with her parents or at my
mom's house where there were numbers
involved
but on august the 8th she said forget it
pack some shit and she left she was a
night coming back till it's over and she
was afraid
i was working 16 18 hours a day seven
days a week
you lost
mike yeah
i have one hey i got a question for you
85 tracking down shoes right it's not
like they were sold on amazon you said
that was a lot of work how long did it
take you to figure out that
it didn't take that long because it was
a brand new shoe okay if it would have
been a reebok
or a nike or something
forever what we did
the guys that we
the guys that we actually pulled off the
golf course
to my buddy they were golfing i said i
need you in here right now
and he said what do you mean i said i
need you to track down this shoe
and they were pissed off because we
brought them in
and i said where do you they said where
do we start
i said start at the orange county line
and work your way west i don't give a
shit find out where it came from
so we found out
that the shoe came from
uh this guy jerry stubblefield who was a
track coach for the oregon ducks
and uh as soon as we found out
the shoe pattern we then we sent one of
our guys from the
crime lab uh work in the physical
section
put him on a plane sent him over there
to meet with jerry it's double filled
and that's where he found out the
shooting that that's where we got all
the distribution charge from
let's talk about you
sitting down and interrogating him and
how that went
richard
was nothing more to me than another
human being
all this bullshit about satanism and all
that
i didn't care because when you stop to
think of it in the simplest form
satanism is nothing more than another
form of religion another faith
so he's nothing more than human
and when i went in that room i wasn't
afraid of him i wasn't afraid of his
satanism he's nothing more than another
human i've got a job to do my job is to
get as much information as i can
out of that individual so i had to have
my game face on and that's what it was
it was a game
so so talking about him having his game
face on or work
uh you know out committing these crimes
i mean he was murder sexual assaults
burglaries kidnappings and so forth
all the time you spend whether that case
or just the you know the 800
murders or so you were involved with you
know people that commit multiple murders
serial murders do you think they are
more
born as such
or made or you know just through through
experiences in life i mean there's a lot
of debate on it that's probably the
second biggest question i get asked
there is a lot of debate there is
and richard looked at me and said gil
why do you think i am the way i am
and i told rich rich
if i could tell you that i'd be a doctor
making a lot more money than i am as a
cop
that's not my job i don't give a shit
why you are the way you are and nobody
can answer that question except for
debate i don't know if he was born like
that if his daddy was a victim of child
abuse yeah his daddy used to beat the
shit out of him and then the guy would
go
to get away from his dad he'd go sleep
in the cemetery
i said rich that scared the be jesus out
of me right you're going to hang around
with it he said no it was the only
complex i could find
and he you know he called me gil i
called him rich matter of fact i'd have
my beard drinking some of your whiskey
if you're allowed yeah we'll let you um
so in la county at the time there were
about eight million people living right
shit i don't know
more like i can't count that high
so
to put that in context we live in
oklahoma above us is kansas and above
that is
some other flat state i think like
canada
yeah and then above that's like north
dakota all of those states don't have
nine million people in them so you're
trying to find a killer within
that
large demographic what do you think
helped you the most other than he was at
moron and criminals aren't very smart
sometimes
i i really don't know i know the week
before he was arrested he went down to
uh mission vehicle
and i remember talking to the captain i
said
we'll have him in two weeks and we don't
even we have the foggiest idea who he is
i said we'll have him in two weeks
he's getting braver he's making mistakes
when he went down to mission vehicle he
says tell him it was me he liked the
word he liked the name night stalker
it's catchy tell him it was me
i was here he's making mistakes
then we found a car
then we found prince
and so
mission vehicle we said we'll have them
in two weeks
and then
the following we ended up we had them in
a week
take luck over skill any day
and i don't know how to say this but we
just got the sign
five minutes
five minutes
you know
we had another guest on a few weeks ago
on our oh five minutes now i see it
that's what
now i see the five minutes thank you
we're looking at each other yeah
we're not looking outward
um well i guess we'll actually we've got
five minutes left
um so just some quick numbers for that
that i'm a detective
i'm just the junior i'm just a dumb
nurse only 25 years not 38. he's a hero
heroes yes
um but richard ramirez he ended up being
convicted for correct me if i'm wrong if
you might know some of this but it's
like 13 murders uh five attempted
murders 11 sexual assaults 14 burglaries
he was actually sentenced to death there
in the state of california but nobody
actually gets put to death in california
and he died in 2013 from medical reasons
is that correct
that is correct june 7th 2013 he knows
dates doesn't he you know i
uh and a partridge in a pear tree god
bless them there's no more
uh
no more appeals it's over with he's dead
he's gone he's done all right what just
one one question here before we do
wrapped it up so your badge number was
187. me being a kid from california i
grew up listening to rap music blah blah
blah but you know 187 is the california
penal code for murder yes it is was that
coincidence you ended up with badge one
eighty seven picket it was it was
set aside for someone else that guy got
promoted to captain i said i'll take it
as a lieutenant that's my badge no well
so uh in tulsa oklahoma 10 15 it means
taking somebody to jail so when we got
we switched from smith and wesson guns
to glocks and all that and we got to
pick uh numbers i was a supervisor of
our gang unit so as a supervisor i was
asked what number i wanted to pick so i
picked 10 15 you know taking bad guys to
jail so to speak so
well guys uh this was a blast having all
of you here was a first for us so
hopefully we could do something like
this again i can't thank you all enough
i thank you for having me yeah i thank
crime con and you
the crime can attendees god bless you
all
i was hoping to get gil drunk so we
could find some other truce out but we
didn't make it that far
um listen we we've got uh i've just been
told from sam over here
our our guy that uh we've got about 10
minutes tops that we can do some
that we can do some q a so if you guys
have some questions out there that you
want to throw sam has the mike general
for lafleur have any questions
jennifer
katie um what's the most surprising
thing he told you during the interviews
i don't know that there was anything
he did surprise me for a millisecond
i'll tell you real quick
he he's he actually scared me for a
second
i was playing
his uh
no more bourbon
hey
lightweight i was trying to raise and
lower his anxiety level to see what kind
of questions i'm going to talk so i want
him to talk to me
so as i'm raising his anxiety level i'm
talking about his sister
and there's no doubt in my mind that his
dad had molested his sister
so as i'm talking to him he's going
almost to the point of hyperviolin
hyperventilation and he had his fist
closed tight
and his fists start coming up off the
table
and i'm looking at him and just for a
millisecond i'm sitting there saying
okay if this son of a bitch starts to
if he starts floating around this room
i'm out of here
[Laughter]
if he starts levitating i'm gone i've
been shot at i've been stabbed but i'm
not gonna fight somebody that's floating
around the room
and so i said hey rich how about a break
you want something to eat
so but he didn't nothing he said
surprised me
he's a regular guy
that liked to murder people
same we got another question out there
anybody right behind we've got sam got
one there and behind you in the red
sean when will live pd be back and if a
kickstarter would help let's go
all right
you know that is the uh that is a very
popular question here today um honestly
i don't know
i can tell you that i know dan abrams
has been very vocal in the media about
it for over a year now
we
everybody involved with the show the
production company those of us that are
on screen and all that trust me we all
want it back it uh
it's
it's something that i don't think is
dead in the water
and hopefully sometime in the near
future we will know something i will say
this i do
think it would probably be on a
different network
um i can tell you that so but uh
they're working on it
hi um what is your favorite whiskey and
do we get to try
a little closer hold the mic closer to
your mouth there we go
yeah yes uh what is your favorite brand
of whiskey and other than your own and
do we get to sample that one oh my
oh that's a loaded question that's like
asking what's your favorite kid
we got lots of kids
we're from the south
we like them all just a little different
way number one show them what's your
number one whiskey
um
definitely not it's not growing out
anybody's listening to podcasts we make
fun of crown apple almost every episode
we just covered this actually very
recently we we discussed this and there
was it's called old elk sour mash batch
one as silly as that sounds that's a
that's a bottle that i really really
like that i'm a huge fan of and then
there's also called a weller foolproof
um big fan of that bottle but just like
you saying between jason and howard and
i think
jason's got upwards of
600 bottles howard's around 400 i'm just
under 300 or so so we have a lot to pick
from we have a problem is what you're
saying yeah
how about you um yeah i'm with you i
like the full proof i like the wheat at
bourbon
i like
what i really like is gil drinking
bourbon that's pretty good over there
look how happy he looks
[Applause]
i think he's enjoying that
all right well guys that is it we
appreciate your time and uh have a great
time the rest this weekend
thank you all
[Music]